take me through your process of writing
a biography that means the the full of
it and I'm not just writing a biography
but understanding
deeply
which your books have done for the human
story and like the bigger ideas
underlying the human story so you've
written biographies both of individuals
which are hardly individuals it's a
really big complex picture and
biographies of
ideas
that involve individuals well step one
for me is trying to figure out how the
mind works
um
what causes Einstein to make that leap
felon musk to say stainless steel while
he's looking at a carbon fiber Rob
rocket or how do you make the mental
leap because I write about smart people
smart people are a dime a dozen they
don't usually amount to much you have to
be creative imaginative to think
different as Jobs would say
and so what makes people creative what
makes them take imaginative leaps that's
the key question you gotta ask you also
ask the questions like you've asked
earlier which is what demons are
jangling in their head and how do they
harness them into drives so you look at
all that and you try to observe really
carefully uh the person of one of the
more mundane things I do
is
a lot of writers
try to give you a lot of their opinions
and preach or whatever
uh as I said this Mentor said two people
types come out preacher's storytellers
be a Storyteller
um
I try
whenever I'm trying to convey a thought
there's six magic words that I almost
should have written on a card
penned above my desk which is let me
tell you a story
so if somebody says how does Elon Musk
figure out good talent
as you did
I think well let me tell you the story
I'll tell you the story of Jake McKenzie
or this is not something I invented I
mean this is where the good Lord does it
in the Bible I mean has the best
openings lead sentence ever you know in
the beginning comma and then it's
stories and secondly to pick up on that
lead sentence in the beginning make it
chronological everybody
in the 40th year of their life has grown
from the 39th year and the 38th year and
so you want to show how people evolve
and grow
I had the greatest of all non-fiction
narrative editors Alice Mayhew at Simon
Schuster who among other things created
All the President's Men with wood and
burns but she had a note she'd put in
the margins of my books that was a tigta
and it meant all things in good time
keep it chronological if it's good
enough of the Bible it's good enough for
you interesting to me like that's a
small note but to you it's it's
extremely important because it's the
framework for how you structure things
but also how you understand things which
is if you keep it a chronological
narrative
then you're showing how a person has
grown from one experience you've talked
about to the next one and that moral
growth creative growth risk-taking
growth
wisdom
that's the Essences of creativity but
you can't do it uh you know there's a
Tom buildings woman you know which is a
you know book of you know that carries a
narrative and tells how people learn
something
I'm a big believer in narrative if
you're an academic
is sometimes not today but in like 20
years ago 30 years ago
there were two things you thought were
bad one was
uh having a great person theory of
history in which you decided to do
biography I had a great Professor when I
was in college her name was Doris Kearns
she later married dick Goodwin and she
when she was going for tenure at the
University
photobiography of Lyndon Johnson and The
American Dream and they denied her
tenure because it was beneath the
Dignity of the academy to write history
through one person
uh that's great it opened up the field
of biography to us non-academics uh
starting with David McCullough
Bob Carroll but maybe John Meacham and
myself are in a new generation and
certainly there's a generation coming
after us
but the second thing besides telling it
through people which
is
the academy tended to disdain what they
called imposing a narrative in which you
made it storytelling because that meant
you were leaving things out and making
it into a narrative
well
that's how we form our views of the
world
well let me ask you this question in
terms of gathering and understanding
how much of it is one observing
and how much of it is interviews
yeah
um and obviously depends on the subject
I mean with Ben Franklin it's all based
on archives and every of course we have
40 volumes of letters he wrote that was
the good old days when every day you'd
write 20 letters
the must book is based much more on
observation than almost any of my books
because he opened up in a way that was
breathtaking to me
you know even when he'd be sitting
playing
politopia or
seething at other people you know he'd
have me just sitting there watching
I mean I spent a lot of time with
Jennifer Dowden at her side I went to
her lab and edited a human gene and you
know with a pipette and a test tube but
I would say I spent
30 hours with her I can't count you know
100 hours and more just observing Musk
and I'm not
sure
that any biographer perhaps since
Boswell took on Dr Johnson has ever had
quite as much
up close meaning five feet away at all
times
access
and because of that I'll go back to what
I said a moment ago I try to get out of
the way of the story it's not about me
is that I try to just say okay
here's what happened here's this story
here's what happened the night he came
in to Twitter for the first time and let
you form your own judgment